Olivier Brou et sa conjointe devait
recevoir leur beaux-parents de Shanghai
en vue du nouvel an chinois cela fait
plus de 5 mois qu'ils attendent leur
visa de touristes pour les accueillir
alors qu'auparavant la prenait en
moyenne entre deux et trois semaines
j'ai essayé d'écrire au consulat à
Shanghai ils m'ont répondu mais ils
m'ont dit qu'ils peuvent pas m'aider
après ça j'ai écrit à immigration ça
reste toujours sans réponse
une situation qui attriste toute la
famille et qui soulève l'indignation de
cet avocat en immigration souvent on
voit ce genre de situation où des gens
attendent des mois où il ne se passe
rien parce qu'en fait aucun agent n'a
ouvert le dossier immigration réfugiés
et citoyenneté Canada n'a pas été en
mesure de répondre à nos questions
cette année les obstacles pour les
voyageurs en provenance de Chine SEM
semble nombreux racontent des membres de
la communauté il faut comprendre que
pour pouvoir venir pour un chinois pour
venir au Canada c'est un peu comme
l'autre parcours d'un combattant les
tests PCR négatifs à l'aéroport pour
entrer au Canada sont de nouveau
obligatoire et les billets d'avion
restera et très chers
depuis des mois un billet d'avion pour
sa mère venue lui rendre visite au mois
de mars pour les D avec son nouveau-né
elles ont finalement trouvé un vol en
novembre dernier ma mère 60 ans et plus
déjà 13h et plus dans un avion c'est
exigeant pour elle donc on a attendu ce
vol spécifiquement la levée des
restrictions sanitaires en Chine
conjugués avec la forte demande des
voyageurs chinois ainsi que pénurie de
main d'oeuvre dans l'industrie
expliquerait en partie la situation
un vol entre Paris et Montréal il y a
plusieurs compagnies françaises
canadiennes de low cost tout ça qui le
font alors que si on va vers la Chine si
on se retrouve avec les vols directs il
y a pas beaucoup de compagnies dans tous
les cas la nid du lapin en est une autre
qui semble commencer sous le signe de la
patience et de la résilience ici Gabriel
prout Radio-Canada Montréal